two and a Half Men is a horrible show
have you seen it it's really just
terrible it's apparently it's still on
which I cannot believe Charlie Sheen is
long gone they have Ashton Kutcher now
and I guess the Half Men the kid he's
off the show entirely Angus T Jones he
left the show after ranting against the
show and calling it filth we've got a
little video of him telling people not
to watch in the first place me Jake from
Two and a Half Men means nothing he is
not existent character he's two and a
Half Men if you watch two and a Half Men
please stop watching two in half man I'm
on to an F man I don't want to be on it
please stop watching it
oh poor kid he made millions and now he
realizes it's filth doesn't want you to
watch anymore but now look at him it
looks like he's turned into someone from
duck dynasty and that was making light
of topics in our world that are really
problems for a lot of people and I was a
paid hypocrite because I wasn't okay
with it but I was still doing it so we
left but in hindsight he says he could
have approached it differently you know
that's his that's his like his baby and
I just you know just totally insulted
his baby and and to a certain attitude
to that degree I am apologetic but
otherwise I'm not
I don't regret saying what I said but he
he's talking about there is Chuck Lorre
who's the creator and executive producer
of Two and a Half Men I think the story
is kind of fascinating because first off
this show is still on the air two and a
Half Men one of the men left now the
half kid left I mean I don't know what's
going on with all that what do you make
of this like that he's trying on
Springer he looks shower they're like
he's going half crazy like how does how
do you sit there take all that money I
did he didn't give it back give the
money back that's the crux of it it's
like are you giving the money back but
don't sit there and talk about the hand
that fed you for however many years my
eraser right exactly like get a Gillette
okay no and don't give the money back
but not only give them my back obviously
he's still getting residuals so it does
it is not just that he got a chunk of
this money years ago he's going to
probably for the rest of his life
in his mind he's like I'm gonna use that
money to spread the word so I'm taking
I'm I'm rich I'm shifting the use of
this bad thing that I did and I'm not
gonna use the money for whatever
frivolous thing I'm gonna use it to
spread my new message so I'm actually
using Chuck Laurie's money for good
right after that I got a defend like I
like that kid doing that sort of moment
like that and that first shot was
wearing those I'm Malcolm X class it's
cool man like I'm I'm into people who
have these kind of awakenings where
they're making a terrible show for like
a a terrible Network that's really
filling people's minds with you know
terrible you know crap anyway and then
all this any wakes up and he becomes if
a fanatic I am I'm into fanatics like
that is more interesting than just
standing up and getting another you know
Teen Choice Award yeah I wish we would
have had video of him between the
Malcolm X stage and then the duck
dynasty stage because that wasn't in
between state you could tell something
out yeah I am I am on board I'm on board
the idea that you're saying of like if
he truly believes that it's look we all
pretty much I think I can speak for all
us and we think the show like that is
crap um so if he really believed that I
kinda there's some credit I want to give
him its call right but anybody who
really has like a strong belief like
that like you got a you got to give it
up to that kid for standing up for
something even though I probably don't
agree with whatever's politics or
whatever it is but like it's kind of
cool that at least you stood up and said
something like it's pretty Punk in that
whole thing yeah so I'm being too glib
about this Angus T Jones no you can I
find it pretty hilarious like I mean I
definitely agree I mean you got to give
it up someone who can wake up on either
side of a thing like the people who come
out of the Westboro Baptist Church I
mean you want it to happen you want it
to be a possibility and create happen
occur camera my god that is insane well
I think the guy thinks a banana fits in
your hand and I'm like that is
ridiculous yeah there's a great Kirk
Cameron banana video we will link to it
in the description is it is it just too
easy though to on Hollywood and and
hit and the the lifestyle here in the
message here bi I've been here for a
year and I guess I probably had some of
those preconceived notions of it's all
these elitist liberal whatever and I
pretty much only met really good people
but I like that I don't get a sense that
they're pushing any agenda
other than they want to sell programming
I don't get a sense that there's like a
real message or some unified thing going
on behind the scenes it's just too easy
to attack Hollywood look that to enough
men show had Charlie Sheen on it forever
who was just was an you know who
do we you know was not great to the
women in his life or was not you know
probably used a lot of drugs publicly so
like I don't know maybe the kids got a
point which is we had a Stan Lee great
to the women or that was the problem
yeah I don't know I mean I I agree with
you that I don't think that this town
proselytizers or pushes some message
like that but I still I still got like a
little love for that kid when he stands
up and grows his hair out and looks like
a weirdo and stands up and does
interviews and you know takes takes a
takes a hit on the chin for like
believing in something which I think in
this you know well maybe in this town
it's rare that somebody believes in
something with that much conviction that
they're willing to stand up against
everything else why is it uh-huh yeah
exactly you're not gonna yeah but why is
it that everyone that suddenly goes the
religious route starts looking crazy
what's that why can't he have made the
move said okay I'm done with this thing
I'm gonna keep that first Malcolm X look
maybe I can just get Warby Parker
instead of that rat look but you know to
me like why do then the hair what why
does that all come I know it seems like
once you go the jump to the crazy
religious train they like hand you a
starter kit yeah it's like here's your
beard here's your crazy glasses they
take away your conditioner interceptor
there's a script of the things you want
to start out saying so that people pay
attention yeah and then probably fade
off into obscurity yeah I don't know if
you guys saw real time this week but
Bill Maher did a great thing on religion
as usual where he talked about you know
you've got these Orthodox Jews that in
the middle of the summer are wearing
wool hats Mormons can't drink hot
chocolate on a cold winter's day and
it's like and now you got this kid who
looked pretty normal and now I mean he
looks like a mountain man yeah yeah if
he looks like the American Taliban today
the other version of it I think